little huddy get on over here mister
rachel nice to meet you great to meet
you i'm chase oh fantastic well you got
your debut album coming out this week
right i do how'd you know that
little bird you told me no but that's
the word around the street so what can
fans expect from your debut album uh
everything man it's from love to
heartbreak and kind of the stages of
everything in between
and you've been working with travis
barker machine gun kelly
that is incredible what has it been like
to have the two of them as mentors and
help you out as you navigate your way
through the business well i think the
two of them are just very
two smart individuals and
i take strong advice from them
like what what's the best advice they've
given you i mean well travis has always
like taught me to keep my head up he's
he's got a a rock of a head like after
20 years of just taking it all in like
i've i listen to him a lot and then um
mgk and i've been friends for so long
he's a great person too nice let me see
those nails cause you've got a new
nail sticker what do you call it these
are semi-cured gel nail stickers oh my
god how did you come up with that
um i don't know it just kind of came to
me we were working for a while awesome
well the fans are loving you guys
tonight
as they should have fun and
congratulations thank you so much